I think a telephone believe it or not is
actually a much better way to connect
with somebody you know zooms are tiring
especially when you have them all day
it's fake you know I'm looking at a DOT
at the top of my screen so that you'll
think I'm making eye contact with you
but really I'm just staring at the dot
at the top of my screen especially when
someone's distracted when you can see
that someone's doing email you know
while you're talking there's no actual
polite way to say can you stop doing
that and listen to me please on the
telephone if you hear someone's
distracted you go hello you there they
go sorry sorry you know you can actually
catch people when I'm on a phone call I
can walk around and I can walk around
wherever I go and I can talk to somebody
and I can be much more engaged I think
we especially for sales people
use the phone pick up the phone how are
you wanted to check in with you you know
have a conversation without Zoom I
actually think it's actually much better
for building relationship Believers
having zooms occasionally is great too
but I think we've forgotten how good the
phone is